foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to add a column to an
existing table in SQL but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple Technologies
if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological Trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from simpler now without further Ado
let's get started with a one point
agenda that is how to add a new column
to an existing table in SQL let's
quickly take a look at the syntax that
we will be using today so we will be
using the alter keyword and the table
keyword followed by that we will be
specifying the table name in which we
want to add a new column then we have
the add keyword and name the column
which you want to add to your existing
table then the data type of that
particular column with constraints if
you have any now that we are clear with
the syntax let's get back to the SQL
workbench where we can execute this
particular command now we are on the SQL
workbench and let us execute this
particular command and see what we have
in our existing table okay I think we
might have to use this particular
command first you need to get the access
to your database then you can get access
to your tables in your database right so
we we have this particular data let's
try to add a new column which explains
about the phone number of a employee
working in your organization
okay now we can use this particular
command which is called the table
there you go so we have added the column
phone number data type and the
constraint not null and if anything is
not added in that particular column the
default value should be n a right let's
quickly execute this particular command
there you go now let's check if the new
column is added or Not by running the
cell command
there you go the new phone number has
been successfully added and by default
since we did not add any number we have
N A in that particular column so that's
how you add a new column to your
existing table in SQL if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if we require
the resources like PPT or data or the
commands we used in this tutorial then
do let us know in the comment section
below and our team of experts will be
more than happy to resolve all the
queries at the earliest until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here